Hi, I'm Phil Slee,
the pastor of Discipleship and Community here at Henderson Hills Baptist Church,
and we are completing our, uh,
community group certification training with looking at the community group
administration coordinator.
Now in the busy life of a community group between the Bible lessons every week
and the, uh, class or outreach social events, uh,
a quiet yet indispensable role often goes unnoticed,
and that's of the community outreach coordinator.
And their responsibilities might just seem mundane to some,
but the importance of this role cannot be overstated.
We're gonna look at three things real quickly,
the big biblical precedence in accuracy and record keeping,
and also we'll look at the, uh,
community group administration coordinator as the unsung hero of the group.
And then lastly,
we're gonna look at some of the duties of the community group administration
coordinator. First of all,
let's look at the biblical precedence accuracy in record keeping.
Now we're gonna draw on the biblical inspiration and examples of numbers.
And first and second Chronicles.
We're not going to be reading much from those passages because these are long
lists of lineage and names and locations and lands and boundaries
and that, but it's a beautiful example of meticulous record keeping.
The book of numbers is an importance because it's, uh,
it keeps meticulous records of the Israelite community.
It details their senses and their genealogies and their land boundaries.
But it's more important than that because we know that God records the work, uh,
his work through his people and his promises,
and the covenant covenants that he's made. Uh,
the countless lists of names and family heritage reminds us
that these names are historical facts. These are real people.
And the practice of meticulous record keeping not only insured organizational
efficiency,
but it reflected the significance of individual responsibilities within the
larger Israeli community. And in First and Second Chronicles,
we witnessed the chronicling of David's lineage and the history of Israel as it
pointed forwards to the coming Messiah.
These books highlight the value of preserving the past and ensuring
the future generations would be grounded in their spiritual heritage and God's
promises and even warnings.
So an accurate record keeping in this context was literally an act of obedience
to God's commands and a testament to the importance of preserving
the heritage, the legacy, the history of God's covenant community.
So number two,
let's look at the community group administration lead as an unsung hero. Um,
they provide what I consider to be the administrative backbone.
And just as record keeping was pivotal in the Old Testament,
the community group administration coordinator plays a vital role in maintaining
the administrative foundation for the class. Uh,
attendance records and reports ensure that the class runs smoothly
and efficiently. And when they do that,
you'll see that there is personal connection.
The administrative leave often interacts closely with the community group
leadership team, uh, and the, uh,
discipleship and community staff in the church office.
They provide accurate attendance records so that group members can be tracked,
their engagement or their disengagement can be addressed. The administration,
uh,
coordinator supplies new information and corrects information so that the
director and the prayer coordinator and the teacher and the Henderson Hills
Baptist Church office can accurately communicate with everyone
on the role.
The administration lead provides the accurate contact information so that, uh,
the, uh, the purposes of the community group can be, uh,
met precisely in the lives of every person on the role.
So this allows for a deeper sense of community and personal connection,
and provides an avenue for the class to support and uplift one another in times
of crisis. And that brings us to the final piece here in that spiritual nursing,
uh, spiritual nurturing, similar to how the, uh,
accurate records in the Old Testament numbers in First and second Chronicles,
how they preserved spiritual heritage of Israel.
The Community Group administration coordinator contributes to the spiritual
nourishment of each class member,
how By recording attendance and contact information,
they create a treasure trove of data that can be utilized by the other community
group members for prayer, or for ministry, or for serving opportunities.
Uh, the list goes on and on,
not just teaching on Sunday morning and keeping a track of attendance,
but also being prepared to minister when a community group member needs us most.
So let's look at a few lessons from Biblical record keeping. Uh, first of all,
obedience and accountability. In the Old Testament,
meticulous record keeping was literally an act of obedience to God.
In a similar way, the role of the community group administrator lead, uh,
it involves commitment to serving with diligence and accountability,
and recognizing that their contributions are a part of a larger spiritual
journey. So, uh, record,
accurate record keeping within the community group context is paramount for a
multitude of reasons. Let's look at a few. First of all,
planning and evaluation.
You've heard some say that without planning,
then there's no plan to succeed.
And so what we're going to learn is that planning serves as a foundation. Uh,
accurate records serve as a foundation for decision making and strategic
planning through precise records. Um, community Group can track its attendance,
its activities, it's projects, it's initiatives,
and that allows the community group leaders to identify what works and what
doesn't, uh, what we can do that seems to be, uh,
resulting in fruitfulness and what we can do that seems to be resulting in
disengagement or apathy.
Accurate records set a roadmap for the future.
It helps the allocation of resources, not just financial resources,
but energy resources, and it helps prioritize the efforts of the team.
Moreover, records are essential for accountability and transparency.
They provide a detailed account of how we can be good stewards
of the funds that God has entrusted to us, and how resources are allocated.
And it's crucial for building trust among members and stakeholders. Uh,
every community group member is a stakeholder in the future development of that
group. And so when they're involved, when they're engaged,
then we know what we are doing for the purpose of God's glory is effective.
Number two, let's look at the metrics and analysis. In addition,
accurate record keeping is instrumental in identifying metrics for evaluation.
By meticulously documenting the group's attendance and activities and
participation data,
it becomes possible to measure the impact and effective effectiveness of the
group. Uh,
this data-driven approach allows community group members to refine their
strategies and optimize their resources for maximum impact. Um, uh,
I can look at a graph of attendance and see, uh,
what is the trajectory of the group. As,
as can any of the leaders in the leadership group.
And perhaps the most important piece of the, uh,
administrator coordinator's role is chasing the strays with, uh,
chasing the strays is just a, uh, uh,
it's a euphemism for how do we contact those who seem to be disengaging
Without your rec, uh, accurate records,
there's a risk of unintentionally losing people,
people falling through the cracks.
Individuals who have participated in events could be, uh,
overlooked if their involvement's not properly accounted for. If they miss, uh,
three or four Sundays and no one contacts 'em, um,
then the community group has missed the opportunity to provide support when
perhaps the group member needs the most ultimately hindering the group's
mission and potential for making positive change for the glory of God. So,
in essence, accurate record keeping not only bolsters the group decision making
capabilities,
but it also ensures that no community group member is left behind.
And in doing so, uh, you literally are providing for a spiritual legacy,
just as in First and Second Chronicles preserve the lineage and history of
Israel.
The work of the community Group administration coordinator contributes to the
preservation of the class's spiritual history,
the legacy of what God is doing and what God has done.
These records capture moments of God's revelation through teaching
transformation through application and obedience and growth,
not just numerical growth, but spiritual growth in the life of each believer.
Which leads us to the final piece here. And that is unity and community.
Uh, accurate records keeping with the, uh,
in line with the Old Testament book of numbers fosters a sense of historical
reliability. Uh,
numbers literally documents the growth and success and traverse and,
uh, trajectory of, uh, God's nation. Similarly,
the administration coordinator's role promotes unity within the community group
by ensuring that everyone is accounted for, all needs are addressed,
and every member feels valued and connected.
And in a world that often prioritizes the grand and the visible,
the role of the community group, mem uh,
administration coordinator stands as a humble,
yet vital contributor to the spiritual growth and com and unity of the community
group. So, drawing on the inspiration from these biblical examples,
we see that this role is not nearly, uh, not merely about administrative tasks,
but also about obedience and spiritual nursing and preserving the heritage
of the Faith community group. So,
just as the Old Testament emphasizes significance of accurate record keeping,
the community group administration administer, uh,
administrator plays a unique and essential part in building a
strong and vibrant spiritual community group.
So let's conclude our time together by looking at the duties of a community
group administration coordinator. First of all, uh,
the thing they do every week is that they prepare and complete the community
group role, and they do so using the community group church builder,
uh, application, this is a, uh,
mobile device application where you literally can use your device, your phone,
if you will, or tablet,
and you can keep track while you're looking in real time at these folks. And,
uh, you're looking for who's attending and who's not attending. Uh,
most of you have already received, uh, an email that looks kind of like this.
And, and it defaults to the fact that you did not meet.
You're not going to receive this email at, uh, at an, uh,
a time that's not planned.
You'll receive this email every week at the exact same time,
and if you don't respond to it, it looks right here, it says, did not meet.
And we know that there, that there's a, a better answer than that.
So what you do is you click on record attendance,
then you go and you record who's there and who's not there every week.
Another thing you do is you look for guests, you introduce yourself,
you welcome them to the class, you make them feel at home,
and then you introduce them to other leaders and other people in the class.
And then maybe one of the most important things you can,
things you can do is you can ask them if they have filled out a profile on the
database. A lot of people don't know this,
but at Henderson Hills Baptist Church using the com Church Community Builder,
c c b application, we have, but one database, all guests,
whether they visited once or many times, including all members,
are all a part of the same database.
That means that we can ensure every guest's name and every member's name
and phone number,
and all pertinent data is in one file that is protected.
And, uh, with, with, uh, state-of-the-art redundancy,
we're not going to lose track of this. And, uh, so what you're doing is,
is you're putting them in a system that, uh, not only is, uh, secure and safe,
but you're making that, that data available for, uh,
all levels of database inquiry.
And so you are the foot soldiers and you're, uh, including that data at the, uh,
at the foot soldier level.
But then there will be other levels of accountability and responsibility that
are gonna help us, uh,
communicate with and respond to needs to those people who come to our church,
whether they're members or not. So, uh, you direct people towards,
this is another thing, uh, that you do.
You direct new people towards enrolling in the community group.
A lot of people don't know this,
but you can belong to a community group and not belong to the church as an
official member. In fact,
community group involvement is a step in the direction towards church
membership. Uh, I said this in a previous training,
but if three different guests come to your community group,
they're not church members, in fact, they're not yet believers in Jesus Christ,
if they'll come and belong to the community group,
one of those three within the year is going to come to faith in Christ,
join the church, and be baptized.
It's an amazing opportunity for us to recognize that God can use our community
group to draw people to his, his ultimate family, the spiritual family.
So you enroll guests in the community group,
you add their names to the class roster,
which means they'll be included in community group communications.
Their birthdays and their anniversaries will be recognized.
We'll be able to celebrate with them,
and that's gonna make them feel a part of the larger whole. And, uh,
the another thing that you do is you keep class membership and,
and information current and correct, uh, children's names and birthdays,
of course, address, telephone, email, all of these,
the communication points are very important that we keep them updated and
corrected. And, and a way that you can do that is also through this, uh,
app. Uh, some of you don't use this, but some of you just do, um,
uh, attendance records, but there are four other opportunities, event notes,
prayer, uh, prayer and prayer request,
and people information where you can report, uh,
you can actually send with a click of a button,
an email to everyone on your roster,
and you can update them about events that are coming up about different
celebration, birthdays and anniversaries. But, uh, and this key,
this piece right here, people in information is key. Uh,
you will have an opportunity to, uh,
report that the guest data here, if they're not in the database,
if they are, all you need is their name.
And it's probably important to get their permission
To, to, uh, to publicize their information to the community group.
If you don't have that, just put their name.
But what's happening there is when you use this resource,
it all flows into the exact same database and then it's protected with
redundancy. And it's also shared with the, uh,
with the pastoral community at the, uh,
staff here so that we can contact them as well.
They'll get an email from Pastor John himself. They'll get a,
a phone call or a text from someone in the community in discipleship ministry.
And so what you see is,
is that it's a combined effort from our church to show someone that if they gave
their information,
that we wanna follow through and let them know that here at Henderson Hills,
you are loved and cared for and valued. Well there, uh,
I want you to hear me say this in conclusion, that,
that you're much more than just a secretary,
much more than just a pencil pusher. Uh, we don't use pencils,
we don't use paper as much anymore.
But what we do is we know the importance of a meticulous attention to
detail as it pertains to the data and information of people who have entrusted
their time with us. And in doing so,
we show them that they're valued and in and, uh,
ultimately to point them to the Lord God, through his son, Jesus Christ.